we do not choose where to be born we do
not choose who our parents are but we do
choose how we are going to leave our
lives I do not choose to be born in
South Sudan a country rife with conflict
I did not choose my name near yuck which
means war have always rejected it and
all the legacy it was born into I choose
to be called Mary as a teacher I have
stood in front of 120 students so this
day does not intimidate me my students
come from war-torn countries they're so
different from each other but they have
one thing in common they fled their
homes in order to stay alive some of
them belong to parents who back home in
South Sudan who are killing each other
because they belong to a different tribe
or the head a different belief others
come from other African countries
devastated by war but when they entered
my class they made friends they walk
home together they do their homework
together
there's no hatred allowed in my class my
story is like that of so many other
refugees the war came when I was still a
baby and my father who had been absent
in most of my early childhood was doing
what other men were doing fighting for
the country he had two wives and many
children my mother was his second wife
married to him at the age of 16 this is
simply because my mother came from a
poor background and she had no choice
and my father on the other hand was rich
he had many cows
gunshots were the order of the day my
community was constantly under attack
communities will fight each other as
they took water along the Nile but that
was not all planes will drop the
spinning and terrifying bombs that chop
off people's limbs but the most
terrifying thing for every single parent
was to see their children being abducted
and turned into young soldier my mother
dad a trench that soon became our home
but yet we did not feel protected she
had to flee in search of a safe place
for us I was four years and my younger
sister was two we joined a huge mass of
people and together we walked for many
agonizing days in search of a secure
place but we could barely rest before we
were attacked again I remember my mother
was pregnant when she will take turns to
carry me and my younger sister we
finally made it across the Kenyan
borders yes that was the longest journey
that I have ever heard in my whole life
my feet were row with blisters to our
surprise we found other family members
that had fled into the camp alia on
where you all are today the Kakuma camp
now I want you all to be very quiet just
for a moment do you hear that the sound
of silence
no gunshots peace at last
that was my first memory of this camp
when you move from a warzone and come to
a secure place like Kakuma you've really
gone far I only stayed in the camp for
three years though my father who had
been absent
most of my early childhood came back
into my life and he organized for me to
move with my uncle to a family in Nakuru
there I found my father's first wife my
half sisters and my half brothers I got
enrolled in school and I remember my
first day in school I could sing and
laugh again and my first set of school
uniform you bet it was amazing but then
I came to realize that my uncle did not
find it fit for me to go to school
simply because I was a girl my half
brothers were his first priority he will
say and he kissing a girl is a waste of
time and for that reason I missed many
days of school because the fees wasn't
paid my father stepped in and organized
for me to go to boarding school
I remember the faith that he put in me
about a couple of years to come he will
say education is an animal that you have
to overcome with an education you can
survive education shall be your first
husband and with these words came in his
first big investment I felt lucky but I
was missing something my mother my
mother had been left behind in the camp
and I had not seen her since I left it
six years without seeing her was really
long I was alone in school when I heard
of her death
I have seen many people back in South
Sudan lose their lives I've had from
neighbors
lose their sons their husbands their
children but I never thought
that that will ever come into my life a
month earlier
my stepmother who had been so good to me
Biki Nakuru died first then I came to
realize that after giving birth to four
girls
my mother had finally given birth to
something that could have made her be
accepted into the community a baby boy
my baby brother but he to join the list
of the dead the most hustling part for
me was the fact that I wasn't able to
attend my mother's burial I wasn't
allowed this sad how family did not have
find it fits for her children who are
all girls to attend her burial simply
because through a girl's they will
lament to me and say we are sorry marry
for your loss we are sorry that your
parents never left behind any children
and I will wonder what are we are we not
children in the mentality of my
community only the boy child counted and
for that reason I knew this was the end
of me but I was the eldest girl I had to
take care of my siblings I had to ensure
they went to school I was 13 years old
how could I have made that happen I came
back to the camp to take care of my
siblings I've never felt so stuck but
then one of my aunt's Antioch I decided
to take my sister's my father sent me
money from Juba for me to go back to
school body school was heaven but it was
also so hard I remember during the
visiting days when parents will come to
school and my father will miss
but when he did come he repeated the
same faith in me
this time we will say Mary you cannot go
astray because you are the future of
your siblings but then in 2012 life took
away the only thing that I was clinging
on my father died my grades in school
started to collapse and when I start for
my final high school exams in 2015 I was
devastated to receive a C grade okay
I keep telling students in my class it's
not about the A's it's about doing your
best
that was not my best I was determined I
wanted to go back and try again but my
parents were gone I had no one to take
care of me and I had no one to pay that
face I felt so hopeless
but then one of my best friend
a beautiful Kenyan lady astor Quecha
called me during these devastating
moments and she was like Mary you have a
strong will and I have a plan and it's
going to work okay when you're in those
devastating moments you accept anything
right so the plan was to organize some
travel money for us to travel to a
Nestor week to girls high school I
remember that day so well it was raining
when we entered the principal's office
who was shaking like two chickens that
had been rained on and we looked at him
he was asking what do you want and we
looked at him with the cat face just
want to go back to school well believe
it or not he not only paid our school
fees but also our uniform and pocket
money for food truck for him when I
finished my high school career I became
the head girl and when I sat for the KC
SC for a second time I was able to
receive a b-minus Club
thank you so I really want to say thank
you to a nest of victory mr. kijima and
the whole and Nesta fraternity for
giving me that chance
from time to time members of my family
will insist that my sis and I and I
shall get married so that somebody will
take care of us they will say we have a
man for you I really hate the fact that
people took us as property rather than
children sometimes they will jokingly
say you're going to lose your market
value the more educated you become but
the truth is an educated woman is feared
in my community but I told them that's
not what I want I don't want to get kids
or 16 like my mother did this is not my
life even though my sisters and I are
suffering there's no way we are headed
in that direction
I refuse to repeat history indicating a
girl will create equal and stable
societies and educated refugees will be
the fault of rebuilding their countries
some days girls and women have a part to
play in this just as much as men
wait we have men in my family that
encouraged me to move on my
half-brothers and also my half-sisters
when I finished my high school career I
moved my sisters to Nairobi where they
live with my stepsister believe
seventeen people in a house but um PD
asked the most important thing is that
they all get a decent education
the winners of today are the losers of
yesterday but who never gave up and that
is who we are my sisters and I and I'm
so proud of that my biggest investment
in life is the education of my sister's
education creates equal and fair chance
for everyone to make it I
personally believe education is not all
about the syllabus it's about friendship
it's about discovering our talents it's
about discovering our destiny I will for
example not forget the joy that I had
when I first had singing lessons in
school which is still a passion of mine
but I wouldn't have gotten that anywhere
else as a teacher I see my classroom as
a laboratory that not only generates
skills and knowledge but also
understanding and hope let's take a tree
a tree may have its branches cut but
give it water and it will grow new
branches for the child of war and
education contain their tears of loss
into a passion for peace and for that
reason I refuse to give up on a single
student on my class in my class
education Hills
the school environment gives you a focus
to focus a head let's take it this way
when you are busy solving mathematical
equations and you are memorizing poetry
you forget the violence that you
witnessed back home and that is the
power of Education it creates this place
for peace Kakuma is teeming with Lana's
over 85 thousands of students are
enrolled in schools here which makes up
40% of the refugee population it
includes children who lost years of
education because of the war back home
and I want to ask you a question if
education is about building a generation
of hope why are there 120 students
packed in my classroom why is it that
only 6% of the primary school students
making it to high school simply because
we do not have enough places for them
and why is it that only 1% of the
secondary school graduates making it
University I began by saying that I am a
teacher but once again I have become a
student in March I moved to Rwanda on a
scholarship program called bridge to
Rwanda it prepares scholars for
universities they are able to get a
chance to compete for universities
abroad I'm now having teachers telling
me what to do instead of the other way
around
people are once again investing in me so
I want to ask you all to invest in young
refugees think of the tree that we
mentioned earlier we had a generation to
plant it so that the next generation can
water it and the one that follows will
enjoy the shade they will reap the
benefits and the greatest benefit of
them all is an education that will last
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]